if you were to advise another actor
actress from the Bay Area I'm coming to
LA and I've heard you say before that
you know life has sped up so much and i
agree i think we're at too fast of a
pace and had a detriment to all of us
but what would you tell that actor
filmmaker that's coming from maybe a
place that's not as fast paced as in LA
or New York in terms of their career and
staying in the moment when they have
everything yeah Twitter coming at you
you have YouTube comments you have
instant updates about whatever in your
gmail god I don't know I don't know what
to tell him except that well first of
all lose the prejudice about LA or
hollywood just lose it because it's here
you know they're the filmmaking is
everywhere now it's here it's in New
Orleans it's in Atlanta it's in North
Carolina it's everywhere there is no
Hollywood anymore it's just an enigma
now so you can just forget all that
stuff and I was I was not very good at
I'm still not very good at
self-promotion you know all the Facebook
and the Twitter you know all the younger
people are teaching me about that so I
would say if you can do anything get
somebody to help you with that so that's
not your focus so so all that stuff is
uh it's it's necessary mechanism but
it's shouldn't be your focus your focus
should be your work just do your work
and whatever happens from that and find
any way to do it like this idea that
everybody's going to come and be famous
is like ridiculous it's are you gonna
are you doing the work because you love
the work and you want to give something
then great then enjoy the hell out of it
and if you get to get a ride like I've
had them great enjoy it but now it's not
about an end result
you